amel bent ça c'est ça c'est une artiste
non mais ces menaces
voilà non mais vous aussi mesdames est
vraiment amel bent elle le sait et amel
comment ça va mais très bien depuis
danse avec les stars ou c'est plus revu
c'est vrai mais c'est vrai de baisse que
de plus vous êtes devenue danseuse
saillé hanouna je vais pas trahir un
secret on sert on s'est croisé cette
semaine alors elle en a parlé on peut
tout dire ici bon alors toi tu vois je
raconte frère m'a dit tu peux alors je
suis en train de déjeuner avec mes
enfants et mon mari et je vois un mec
celle où il fait 40 degrés voilà je vous
explique 40 degrés je vois un mec chelou
habillés en costume trois quarts 3 034
personnes c'est-à-dire le gilet la
chemise le truc en beaucoup moins beau
gosse sur une trottinette
tu m'as pour batterie est logique avec
un mec au scooter derrière qui est celle
qui tient une batterie comme ça et en
fait nous
[Applaudissements]
la france et sa série s'est pas blessé
mais quand je t'ai vu j'ai dit mais dis
moi c'est quoi ça métier magnifique fois
c'était schéma et non encore plus belle
qu'avant les antilles je suis très
heureux de te voir ma belle tu vas dort
jamais mais qu'est ce que c'est mais qui
se succèdent des bombes atomiques là
sans rigoler c'est exceptionnel vous dit
rien la personne ne dit rien alors ça
passe à la télé comme ça personne ne dit
rien quoi ça vous êtes couché vomir là
les autres noms mais les deux sont en
discussion
ouais alors oui c'est dans ce petit
change à la 7 chez qui ça intéresse à
[ __ ] en tout cas c'est pas déjà dit ça
te va très bien je voulais discuter un
peu
inquiétez pas les pulls sont très
longues ici vous allez pouvoir du moment
cause est belle mais c'est vrai et bien
les mêmes et n'hésitez pas si vous
voulez je crois que c'est un club de
rencontre mais sont maintenant et il ya
des gens qui nous regardent la
haute-vallée pardon à beloeil alors
rappelé la rencontre la plus marquante
de toute votre carrière il paraît que
c'est charles aznavour ah ben oui c'est
vrai c'était un bon gars moi c'est un
monsieur que j'écoutais de faire depuis
tout petit gilet mais j'ai vraiment
écouté que charles aznavour pendant des
années et pour moi l'avoir rencontré
avoir travaillé avec lui chez passé
c'est comme un miracle qu'on va pas nous
faire un petit qu'un petit charlesbourg
a cappella comme ça
ouais mais attends je vais prendre une
que personne sauf un qui est moins connu
que les autres comme ça sera oui
découvrir en même temps prenez le comme
lui j'aimerais direction j'ai pété les
plombs
savourez fait deux pigeons s'aimaient
d'amour tendre
mais l'un d'eux a quitté leurs toits
qu'ils sont non les jours de attente est
longue ce sont les nuits sans toi un
pigeon regretter son frère moi je
regrette mon bel amour
comme on lui dit j'attends un bruit dans
le doux bruit des deux de sombres tous
amel bent elle connaissait pas la télé
c'est pas cela ces deux pigeons c'est
dingue je savais pas il a fait chaud
d'eau sur deux pigeons savait pas qu'il
a fait une chanson sur thierry moreau
jean clair et vous est ce que vous
connaissez une chanson de jenifer bien
évidemment la quasi plus
mais plus ça que l'homme à bord et
réchauffer son corps
gfr